this is a big moment on the podcast
because as we know sona's about to give
birth to twins which means
that things are going to change around
here and there's a bit of a transition
in process
conan sona we also are welcoming someone
very special here today
david hopping david welcome thank you uh
david hopping let me explain
uh is going to be filling in for sona
david's been with the show how many
years have you been on the show david
around four
four years okay four years yeah almost
five
2016. okay you know one thing we do on
this podcast is we keep the answers kind
of
terse so no one cares if it's four or
five yeah
someone might uh no one person my mom
cares
even your mom is like whatever david
move on she's so happy
she's at home she's so glad i'm not in
illinois she's at home saying
that's so david four no five no wait
four
no four and a half david you've been on
the podcast before remember in the first
quarantine episode so listeners might
know david
yeah david you have taken on a very
sacred role
sona many people say is the beating
heart of
the podcast conan o'brien needs a friend
i am the mind
sona is the heart and uh matt gourley
uh is there's an organ behind the spleen
that we don't know what it does it's
more some people think it's just a piece
of cartilage
but people are saying i'm the libido of
the podcast hey
there you go yeah i suppose i suppose
sexual energy
you're the sexual energy that uh i mean
just look at me i'm in a plaid shirt
in a plaid shirt yep you are raw
sex appeal but this is
an important time for us because while
you're here sona
you need to help david understand what
his role
on the podcast is going to be now he has
worked at the show as he said for five
years yeah
but he may not know what his job is here
and it would probably make sense for you
to try and walk him through it
so wait yeah we should be clear taking
over for me on the podcast as well
i just thought it was not weird just
yeah oh this is breaking news what are
you
you're what are you doing well i assumed
that if you're leaving we need another
person here it's
you know there's got to be three of us
okay oh no that's cool
i i think david probably wanted to know
that as well
and now i do so that would have been
nice information for
welcome david to know so yeah i'm just
assuming we need a third voice uh
there is no um the strongest shape is
the triangle
huh okay i think i don't even think
that's true i just said that
i i'm with you though just so long as it
doesn't have to be you and me awkwardly
trying to get through an intro it'd be
nice to have david there
well the first thing david is
communication is lacking
on this entire oh you weren't aware that
david's going to be
filling in your role in the podcast i
don't think anyone was aware until right
now
am i wrong hey wait a minute maybe i'm
wrong i just assumed that was a good
idea adam what's happening here am i
right
uh yeah i mean i think it's a that's a
good idea but the the conversation was
going to be
about david kind of filling in persona
as your assistant and and getting up to
school
i thought we were permanently replacing
i thought we were permanently replacing
sona
permanently well yeah you're a mom now
you can't be doing this [ __ ]
what are you talking about i assumed
that we were getting rid of sona
she's out the door and we're bringing
david in oh my god david run
uh run away as fast as you possibly oh
yeah you don't want to make a lot of
money just
gabbing on the radio occasionally with a
comedic legend who needs that
come on i'm not a comedic legend you are
you are considered a comedic legend
weren't you a voice at disneyland
yeah i was a trash can there you go and
you know what to me you'll always be a
trash can
um no no i don't i i just think he's
here today
and i'm going to be honest with you i
think if he hits it out of the park
today
who knows this could be it this could be
your farewell episode sona so just
you've got to um you got to be on your
toes today sona okay the hell is this
i like to pit people against each other
that's what lauren did at sign out live
and it made that show hum you know
did you see that your rival got a sketch
on are you feeling nervous conan
oh look rival now conan's doing well you
know that's the kind of thing that makes
that show
uh so uh superlative and that's what i
want to do here
i want to pit you and uh is it david
yeah i want to pit you and david against
each other and see uh you know
and that's gonna make both of you
fantastic you can't you know why
because we've already established david
and i are on our team
we're allies and you are the enemy
so this is how we approach this entire
thing you stand to gain you stand to
gain here david this could really change
your life oh wow how old david how old
are you 29. you're 29 years old yeah i
don't know what your income is
but um you're his boss do you want to
give me more while we're here
look i don't does the pharaoh know every
detail of the pyramid's construction
no he visits the pyramid every couple of
months and eats a fig and takes a look
at it and says looks okay to me
then tens of thousands of people very
short life expectancies
uh move the stones around that's sort of
my role
i'm the pharaoh got it so i don't know
exactly what you make but i imagine if
you became a regular part of the podcast
um you would you know bump up quite a
bit in your life so
can i get this straight i'm sorry real
quick are you
firing me because i'm having babies i
looked into this okay
you know what i looked into this and
trust me i looked into it i got
i've got some um i had so many layers
involved um
no okay i i am not firing you because
you're having babies because
i'm told that plan that i had is not
legal and is morally wrong okay so
that's not happening
okay you had to be told that is morally
wrong okay
it doesn't either way i've i think we've
come to a good conclusion for you
which is that you will be welcomed back
with open arms as soon as you're ready
to return here oh okay at a reduced
salary
hey there it is well i'm sorry but i
don't think there's a law against that
there is oh right they did tell me that
yeah there is there absolutely is
i'm you know what i keep forgetting what
the lawyers told me yes that's right yes
same salary or probably even higher yeah
yeah i'm sorry
i have my plots and schemes and then um
it's very good they always bring lawyers
in to explain to me
that i can't do that that that hasn't
been most of what i
want to do to the staff hasn't been
legal since 1840
1840 in england and uh 1978 in america
so uh a lot of this seems like common
sense though
but uh it does it does you'd think but
it it really isn't
as i'm proof um but let's let's start
with then let's say that
he's not replacing you on the podcast i
was trying to pull a fast one
okay and seeing if i could maybe you
just go oh good for you and then i would
have
audio record of you're resigning that
didn't happen
um you oh you you you were trying to
bait me into quitting
i just thought maybe it would happen and
we would have uh what my lawyers said
was proof
i also think there would be an uproar if
sona permanently left the public yeah
sona
you're going to go to one of your other
hit podcasts me and mr quibbles
uh ships in a bottle talk just go on
maternity leave with me
of course i'm being funny i have to
point that out because that's what
really funny people do
but my point is this uh matt gurley is a
very successful podcaster long before i
stumbled onto this scene
i make these jokes but they're absurd
and they're wrong i i denigrate you for
no reason matt
and i should be honoring you instead
sona of course you're always welcome
here you are the heart as i said it's a
podcast
that's nice and uh had you uh
voluntarily been tricked into resigning
i might have taken you up on it but you
didn't
and so you will be returning soon i hope
i wasted a lot of time on this
segment trying to trick sona into
resigning it didn't work
yeah but now we get to the meat of the
issue which is
uh sona is going to explain her duties
and this is going to be hilarious
because i think she has no idea
what a professional assistant does so
tune in to that
uh wonderful uh piece of chicanery and
tomfoolery
on the next episode of conan o'brien
needs a friend wow this is exciting
this is our first ever segment
cliffhanger it's yeah what a cliffhanger
this is our this is instead of who shot
jr
or uh what is rosebud mean uh we our
version of that on this show
is sona explains what an assistant does
to a relative stranger
it gives me time to figure it out yeah
we'll see you next week